new technology is helping the clark
county school district fight covet 19 in
the classroom today they unveiled the
ark which is basically a uvc light used
to disinfect kate houston live from
cashman middle school over on di and
decatur a school that will use this to
explain when it will be used kate
yes well this technology is needed as
positive cases continue to spread across
the district now the plan is to have all
372 schools
given an arc device this will cut down
on the use of chemicals and add more
protection in schools
using this once a day will give you a
monumental improvement in
the health and safety of whatever
classroom this is the ark a hospital
grade uvc light that destroys 99.99
percent of pathogens in an empty room in
less than seven minutes it has enough
energy to inactivate any kind of virus
bacteria mold and fungi
on any surface or in the air this will
be a new layer in the school district's
safety strategy and will disinfect a
school if there is an outbreak it will
not be used in every classroom every day
having it being used in the restrooms in
the health office multiple times a day
those are high load areas and then
a few rooms each evening and a lot of
schools are working on a schedule to
have
each classroom done at least once a week
this technology comes as the school
district surpasses one thousand covid19
cases concerning parents like melissa
valle i'm sending her to school
and just hoping that she doesn't come
home with kobe while she wants more to
be done valle is optimistic that this
could help slow the spread hopefully the
sanitation you know will help with that
and bring some relief to a lot of his
parents who are concerned for that in
addition to the coronavirus the ark can
also kill the flu common cold e coli and
norovirus ccsd chief of facilities jeff
wagner says this technology is now a
long-term investment when we get the
pandemic under control we will still
have need in our classrooms to keep them
disinfected
uvc is a skin and eye irritant so these
are placed in empty classrooms which are
then safe to go into afterwards now this
device will shut off if somebody
accidentally walks into that classroom
and all staff will be going through
training for this if they're going to
use that device reporting live outside
of cashman middle school kate houston 8
news now